So what happens to the brain when we learn? Actually the brain physically
changes. Hebb's law states that Neurons that fire together, wire together. And
that's exactly what's happening when we're learning. When you're repeatedly
engaged in a particular behavior, or your learning something. Those synaptic
connections are actually growing and becoming stronger. However the opposite of
that is also true, meaning that if we stop using that information, or stop
engaging in those behaviors. Those connections are going to weaken, that can
result in forgetting and memory loss. Here the phrase practice makes perfect is
actually quite relevant, in fact research shows that it takes approximately
10,000 hours of practice to become an expert. So if you wanted to be an expert
piano player, you'll have to practice for about 10,000 hours. So remember that
practice, use, and rehearsal, all help us to remember the things that we've
learned.